here now with reaction the author of
trial of the Century Fox News legal
analyst Greg Jarrett and former Florida
attorney general Pam Bondi Greg Pam
thanks for being here so once maybe a
coincidence Greg twice from two
different federal agencies same guy
releasing dangerous information maybe
it's coordinated I don't know
yeah I don't believe in coincidences uh
Pete you know is it a coincidence the
IRS goes after taibi right after he
exposes the FBI for its lawlessness and
then you know the IRS shows up magically
at his house the same day he testifies
in front of Congress you'd have to be a
gullible idiot to not see the obvious
connection it's a pattern of abuse by
Joe Biden's government if you report on
corruption then corrupt actors will
immediately Target you you know you've
seen it with Biden's IRS the doj the FBI
the Intel Community they will descend on
you like locusts they want to frighten
and intimidate to shut you down to
silence you and to his great credit
taibi will not be bullied and he
revealed what the IRS did they moved to
punish him for free speech that they
just didn't like and when he exposed it
you know the IRS comes up with all these
transparent lies to cover up what they
had done this is the same Mo at the
department of Injustice the FBI they're
like Richard Nixon's dirty tricksters
you remember they compiled an enemies
list well Joe Biden has got one and
he'll sick his attack dogs on you if you
dare to criticize
yeah Pam you know you were the top cop
in in Florida is it common practice that
on Christmas Eve on a Saturday someone
who's just now made it into the news
faces a probe
boy I wish that it was possible to get
people out on Christmas Eve on a
Saturday to investigate crimes and this
wasn't even a crime Norris is what our
Founders intended our government to be
you know what the IRS mission statement
is is to help people understand their
tax responsibilities and to enforce the
law with integrity and fairness to all
really you know so now we're learning
that they are using being used by the
FBI to intimidate to threaten to bully
anyone who's going to stand up or Cross
or speak against the FBI so now we have
another one to add to our list who's
truly been weaponized by the Biden
Administration and it again it should
frighten all Americans what they're
doing
for sure Greg do we have any sense of
where these things emanate from is this
a is this a is this who makes the call
and not that you would know but you've
done so much reporting so much writing
on how these things come together the
corruption the collusion uh the effects
the attempts to weaponize government
weaponize Justice is this is this a need
to know basis arm's length distance from
the White House to the doj you have your
marching orders go ahead and do it how
do these things get executed
well either indirectly or directly by uh
the big guy uh who we now know from uh
the laptop is is Joe Biden look there
there are plenty of Rogue people running
around doing what they think Biden wants
them to do but one wonders you know
during Watergate Richard Nixon was
directing a lot of it personally
especially the cover-up and the the
evidence is overwhelming Pete you've got
these malign government actors running a
protection racket for the bidens you
know it you know makes the mob look
quaint and small by comparison you know
whistleblowers and you were talking
about this a moment ago they offered
compelling evidence that the criminal
probe into Biden influence peddling met
a brick wall by the president's own
appointees U.S attorneys and others who
are intervening the FBI buried
incriminating evidence and you know
these whistleblowers describe naked
favoritism political interference in a
case that directly implicates Joe Biden
in apparent crime so he has every motive
to be directing these malicious acts
retribution retaliation seeking the IRS
on people uh you know one wonders is it
in the Oval Office
yeah maybe there's tapes maybe we'll
find out someday Greg there was once
maybe twice uh Pam we're about to enter
we are in presidential primary season we
are in the place where candidates
fortunes are going to rise and fall and
Donald Trump made a statement recently
about hey wait until they come after you
to his top opponent in the Republican
primary what assurances would any
Republican have I mean Donald Trump was
weaponized for he has they've gone after
him for years we know that but why
wouldn't they use similar tactics
against any other Republican that's
rising in the ranks and and how do you
guard against that can you
Pete they can't and they will and we
know they will and remember when Donald
Trump said they're not coming after me
they're coming after you and I'm
standing in the way and this is the
perfect example of it and with the IRS I
guarantee you there is going to be a
paper trail of it and Jim Jordan will
find it because these people think
they're Above the Law the IRS the FBI
the justice department because if
they're working in concert with the
Biden Administration they think nothing
can happen to them and that's why
they're going to come after all of our
candidates anyone who will cross them
they went after a journalist who's not
going to be intimidated by them and yes
it's going to catch up with them and
thank goodness again we took back the
house because Jim Jordan in Congress
they're going to get to the bottom of it
they have to for all Americans people
yeah I think I think I think Kevin
McCarthy Jim George James Comer and
others have have taken their mandate to
do what they can uh but Greg I would ask
this to both of you if you were if you
were in the Oval Office the day after a
new Republican president were elected
what would your directive be to them to
correct this two-tier justice system how
do you rip it out and change it
let me start with Greg go ahead I'd
start with the FBI dismantle and
deconstruct it and build it Anew look
the the bread and butter of the FBI uh
the rank and file these are honest
honorable people they do great work it's
it's you know the Hoover building uh you
know the seventh floor and and it is
absolutely Riven with corruption then
I'd move to the Department of Justice
and I'd clean house there to make sure
that it is honest in the way that they
pursue cases you know you don't go after
Catholics uh you know as terrorists you
don't go after parents who dare to
complain at school board meetings uh you
protect uh justices when they're being
threatened justices of the U.S Supreme
Court you enforce the law after all when
you're sworn uh in as president you're
you're sworn to uphold and execute
Faithfully all the laws it's about time
we had a president who actually did that
Pam you know you saw the the outrage the
the fainting outrage when James Comer or
James Comey was was fired or Annie
McCabe can barely get removed so whoever
does this is going to face an onslaught
like they've probably never seen
yeah well and again I would say exactly
what Greg said it starts at the top with
Justice you put in an attorney general
who is not scared of anybody and will
take out the people who are not honest
they're throughout the justice
department but there are some great real
prosecutors in the Justice Department
you move on to the FBI replace them move
those guys all over the country if you
can't fire them disarm them put the good
Street agents to work to do the job they
were put there to do protect children go
after kidnappers child pornography and
then you continue on with DEA give them
more resources to fight this
International drug crisis we're facing
Homeland Security strengthen them don't
cut them build the wall and do
everything that President Trump did his
first term and what Biden is not doing
now to protect Americans that's pretty
easy
that would apply to every agency so the
onslaught would be total from the
bureaucracy but that would mean you're
right over the target Greg and Pam thank
you both appreciate it hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else